maybe antitrust laws are there for a
reason maybe we should be having more
than just a handful of internet service
providers who are vertically integrated
and also own the programming okay that's
that's number one we have many of these
laws on the books there's been no
appetite from republicans or democrats
really in enforcing this stuff you do
hear sometimes from democrats we got to
break up this that the other thing we've
heard it from bernie elizabeth warren
not uh
nearly the topic that it should be
that's one story
second story
cnn
has done a bunch of critiques of oan
okay they've exposed oan's lack of
journalistic integrity and they did it
accurately
um
does cnn know when they do that
that the parent company is the same
they're owned by warner which is owned
by at t and uh at t is that it's not
owned but is the main funder of oan
it wasn't mentioned in the segments that
were done on cnn makes me wonder whether
they even know it if either way you
would think it's something that should
be disclosed